our studio just got a massive upgrade  and it has to do with maps and I just  watched this oh  State we have a map of the massive  beautiful states of Hawaii and Alaska oh  we're just getting started Nick let's  get another one that one right there yes  please all made possible by this  beautiful mounting hardware  oh yeah unravel my favorite map of all  time we've got Switzerland oh my gosh  look at that beautiful top part I mean  look at this look at this this kind of  stuff makes me swim it's the most  gorgeous map of all time and we have  atlases road maps of Europe from like  the 1970s to the old Maps here done some  stuff from like the 1400s or something  this is where I work and this is where I  also look at Maps some are just like  hanging on the wall too you know all  right let's get the big boy this is a  new one yep here comes